welcome to this video let's vary with if
five my usual response but of course I'm
trying to play all kinds of openings
let's go for the Schliemann move for
once
pretty good opening really one of the
best gambit style openings around okay
the white now has fun some choice this
is yeah this is one of the moves ninety
force what I prepared a while ago
against this but of course it's it's
been a while and I forgot the most most
of the lines so he prevents castles for
a moment interesting
nights mm-hmm yeah maybe he wants to
combine Bishop g5 95 okay
hmm yeah okay I keep it simple here or
should I take with the night even none
of this this should be fine
yeah he needs to take with the bishop
taking with the pawn is almost like
resigning the game okay so Bishop takes
I still cannot castle short okay I don't
need to do that can also casts a long
snow no big problem
okay so I can just take him and try to
to hope this position it's not too
attractive
what about Knight to g4 in this position
94 rook F seven and then Queen to h4 I
don't know but it doesn't look doesn't
look too convincing okay let's play this
first and then think about that again of
course I need to get one pair of rocks
off
hmm
this is completely crazy 94 Kevin Quinn
age who is got Bishop g4 check
completely completely nonsensical
disodium
okay so g6 maybe
yeah it's a bit it's a bit tricky
okay let's get out of this check this
Bishop e6 with the check
so he prevented that
how to play that really unsure here
should I say some idea to check it it
doesn't really let me any benefits I'm
thinking about getting the Queen over
but it doesn't really it doesn't really
help
my idea is just g5g for yeah okay this
is just just the thought yeah
no way that this is working yes your
attack here this yeah yeah maybe it's a
draw and this is possible because I
cannot really interpose with the Queen
okay but I can't I can't play that
now you probably has a draw
more than that would be it would be
hugely we checked but okay yeah he's got
more than that sir
chess is a strange game sometimes I can
use just second a six without anything
sometimes this crazy stuff is working
but can hi morning you know I don't have
food don't have a move
shiny check yeah maybe Bishop e6 was
really working it's hard to believe at
least it doesn't have any logic to me
check
you take some good chocolate aged free
check
yeah I'm down on ten seconds without
that I would even be pretty optimistic
here like simply because he plays such
strange stuff here it would understand
us again
check 5 seconds is really not enough
check
check
check
yes going to win on time coming for
channel sunshine what the heck
no challenge yeah so maybe this the
special basics was really working I
think this is quite amazing actually
okay so played g5 here again no the
complex s is this as a draw
okay instead of g5 I can play d5 with
the little bling with just winning
idiotic
just this idea it's very easy
I'm just winning crazy yeah and I could
have played them d5 for for for ages and
I never did Wow just e5 and white
resigns just like that this is of course
the idea yeah somehow I was aware that
black is is okay here but I didn't I
didn't didn't see that at all okay then
he played this weird second a6 that is
based on the fact that I'm have a bit
tight here
Roxy ages draw and had this probably and
this is losses again due to a six rook
c8 is still a draw
yeah but I need to play d5 of course
this was you know after okay three heats
the go to f2 and then that this is just
a normal position with not much not much
happening and luke f3 just invites this
d5 winner yeah
the simply simply lost lost chance here
thanks for watching